we're going to begin this hour heading
back to tony decouple he is in texas ted
tony we know it's going to be another
very hard day for the families there
because they are now members of a club
that no parent wants to be in
yeah that's right gail the sun is coming
up here on on day two of the day
everything changed here in uvalde texas
and we're going to learn more of course
about what happened but also what it
cost this community some of the things
families are saying my one and only baby
my sweet baby sister the keeper of my
soul
just three of the ways that family
members are describing the 21 people
murdered here you see them on your
screen now
and as we think about all of them we
also want to show you a little bit more
of our conversation with angel garza
whose daughter amory was killed on
tuesday because i think it shows the
trade-offs here uh the human costs of a
disturbed young man having the freedom
to buy a weapon in his own community
and then turning it on a local school a
school in that very community garza told
us that he went to rob elementary school
behind me when he heard about the
shooting
and he just wanted to help
i hear someone crying inside that's her
mother
there was a
i i'm
i'm a media so i went over there and
there was a little girl
covered in blood head to toe man soaked
in blood and
she had you know plasma in her hair
it looked like you know she got hit i
thought she got hit
she was hysterical and
she said that she was fine she said that
they shot her best friend
she said my daughter's name
what's your daughter's name amerie
what's her last name amy garza
what kind of little girl was she
she was the s
she was the sweetest thing she's she's
so creative she just got award for being
the most creative
she doesn't hurt anyone she doesn't
believe she does the right thing
but i have a fourth grader also
um i don't know what to do man i just
she didn't deserve that no she didn't
no she didn't
angel doesn't know what to do there his
family's got a long road ahead they told
us that the memories are just too thick
on the ground here around this school
they came back to get closed yesterday
and then they're going to go out of the
area because it's just too difficult
what to do though is a question that the
next generation is confronting there's a
non-profit group i want to tell you
about it's called students demand action
and they're urging walkouts today at
schools all across the country guys uh
they're calling for change and as i send
it back to you i'll tell you their
mission is a mission that i think a lot
of people share in this country a hope a
belief that we can we can
we can make it possible that other
families will not be forced to do what
the families here are doing which is in
the days ahead having to bury their
children because of gun violence
we can make it possible tony because
this is so preventable i think that's
the other thing that's so frustrating
this does not have to happen in the in
the united states of america and it
continues to happen tony we thank you